From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Okay, let's go.
Alright, today is Saturday, March 9, 2013.
My name is Will Griffin and I am a research associate with the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill, or History Program.
I am with a videographer, John Bishop, and Albany Georgia on the campus of Albany State University to conduct an interview for the Civil Rights History Project, which is a joint undertaking of the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture and the Library of Congress.
We are here today with Miss Grace Miller who played a prominent role in the local Baker County Movement.
Thank you so much for being here, Miss Miller, and agreeing to share your story with the Civil Rights History Project.
So first, I would like to begin with you stating your full name, date, and place of birth.
My name is Grace Hall Miller.
My date of birth was due July the 21st, 1932.
So could you talk a little bit about your upbringing, your parents, and...
Yes, my father was named Joe Nathan Hall.
Okay.
My mother was named Nanny Hall, and I was the sixth child, six of us, and I was the baby of the group.
And we would be in the end of Baker County.
My father was a farmer, and my mother was a housewife.
I grew up with the school in Baker County, and church also, and I met my husband, he's the Baker County, too.
His name was Jose Miller Sr., and we got married in 1946, then in 1946, in Baker County.
And we got married secretly.
And his oldest brother told the family he found out some way that we had got married,
because I had to go to school right on.
And my parents were so upset because I was the baby.
I didn't know how to cook, I didn't know how to wash, I didn't know how to do anything.
And he told my parents, they said, my baby don't...
She just can do it.
And she said, you know what?
She said, whatever she does is fine with me.
She said, you don't have to cook it, she don't have to go out to the house.
I would do the cooking, my husband was a...
And I had his oldest in me.
So we got married, and we had a beautiful married life.
We had five girls and one boy.
And he was a great father.
Those girls, they took him from me.
They were calling him, they had dad.
And a lot of times I would be jealous because he would take them...
He was just a good father.
He could go on those kids.
I wouldn't really jealous of the kids.
But I wanted some of the attention that he gave them.
And he would always tell me, say, you know you got my attention.
Don't worry about it.
You might be able to.
And he found...
We had a farm.
That was his occupation of farmer.
That was the house way.
Taking care of the kids.
And on March.
Can we just back up a little bit before we move so fast?
I want to find a little bit more about your relationship with your parents.
And the types of things that they instilled in you.
You said you were the babies.
So obviously there was a lot of attention built out to you.
Oh, really?
So what do you remember about your parents the most?
Well, I was the baby of the family.
And I was the teller to you.
My oldest still will go.
And my mama will say, take her with you if you want to go.
And they will do things to them.
Tell your mama and dad about it.
I said no.
That night when we getting the bed, I would tell them everything.
So you're curious who you will aspire to.
They knew I was the one to get the news.
But I had a good mother.
They were church workers.
My father was deacon of the church.
Okay.
What church was this?
I was just talking about the church.
I remember that church now.
Okay.
Do you remember some of the lessons there?
I mean, obviously religion and other things that they instilled in you.
We had to go to Sunday school.
We had to go to prayer meeting.
We had to go to BTU at church.
And they taught us value.
My parents really taught me value.
To treat others as I would have them treat me.
Right.
And the main thing, my father taught.
He didn't like for nobody to steal.
And he taught us if you want something, you ask for one.
And if you can't get it, then don't bother.
Right.
And it will stay in me until the day.
Okay.
That that don't have, I don't bother.
And I taught my children the same thing.
Be honest with whatever in their jobs, whatever they do, and to that.
People that they deal with, be honest and treat them fair.
Right.
And that's the way I grew up.
Okay.
Loving everybody.
I think if you go in my community, they'll tell you that I get along and I love everybody.
Okay.
And I grew up with that knowledge of treating people like you would have them treat you.
So, let's talk about your early education.
What were the schools like in Baker County that you attended?
My early education, we had a walk school.
And it was about two miles from my home.
Wow.
And it would be cold.
It would be real cold.
And we would get the school and I would tell my dad, the teacher said, well, we need some wood.
And I'd tell my dad, when we get home, I said, dad, I said, my teacher, say, we need wood.
I wouldn't sleep until he got that wood.
He had to go get it.
And stack it up and put it where I could see it to know that we'd have a fight at the
next day at school.
And the kids had the bus to ride.
They would pass through there with us, those spitballs after us and we would freeze them.
They had a bus.
But you know what, we kept going.
That time, you didn't have any modest against them because we grew up thinking, you know, that's the way life was.
And we were all back then.
And from high school, I mean, from elementary, we had to go to Newton down to a city of Newton to the high school.
Okay.
What was the name of the high school?
Newton Baker County, color high school.
They had Newton Colored High School.
That's the name of it.
But my husband's parents didn't let them go to school in Newton.
He then drive to Camilla.
All of his kids was educated in Mitchell County, Georgia.
Mitchell County, Georgia?
Uh-huh, because he felt that I school just when I, you know, everybody at that time,
weren't able to take back his to out of the county.
Right.
But he was able to take his kids to Mitchell County, Georgia for an education.
Okay.
So, while you were in school, do any of your teachers stand out?
I mean, some of the...
Oh, yes.
I was here for teachers.
So, teachers that felt hard, you know, they were just dedicated teachers.
Miss Granbare, one...
Granbare.
She's from...
She's from Albany, Georgia.
She taught down there in Baker County.
We had Miss Smith from Albany, Georgia taught us.
And we had a teacher, a principal name, is Bradley and the Erdo Metric Land.
And we had to do what was right.
We said, Bible verses every morning, we had to pledge allegiance to the flag.
And we learned songs.
And we learned poems.
You know, and those poems and Bible verses is with me today.
Okay.
I think if you start off teaching a child at an early age about God and life and how to live,
you know, go along with them.
But today's time, they can't teach that kind of thing.
And I believe that's why we are having so much trouble in our school,
because they're not being taught the right, you know, about life skis.
They're not being taught about it.
Even now in our school, we don't have home making them own.
Right.
And see, those teachers back there taught home making.
They taught you how to sew on buttons on your clothes.
They taught you how to cook and how to save.
See, now they don't teach those things.
And I cheer them, they're so wasteful.
And they don't know how to be upset, you know, how to save.
And I think if we could go back to some of those old days,
our whole kind of world would be in a better shape.
Okay.
So now what type of student were you in the high school?
I was good student.
Good student.
I was a little bit bitch.
I would have one of those excellent, you know, A students all the way to the A and B.
What you did, what you were supposed to do.
So what year did you graduate?
It was in 50.
50.
Okay.
And now let's move on to the time that your husband, as old folks say,
start courting you.
When did you meet him?
And what do you recall about that first time you met him?
Oh, see, his parents are like, my, we had to go to church.
And we used to go to B to you on the Sunday evening.
B to you, what does that stand for?
That's for you, Bible, you've, Bible teaching you, you've planned.
Okay, Bible teaching.
And we thought he's talking, looking at me and talking,
and I was, Fred, I knew I was old enough to start dating, as they say.
So he kept, was deaf, going to church, and he kept talking.
And we secretly encoded because I wasn't really old enough.
My parents didn't know I was dating.
So after I got to high school, we stopped playing basketball.
And I was living with my oldest sister.
And that night, particularly night, he carried me home.
And we started talking to each other.
Let's go, Mary, you know, back then, those times you didn't have to have blood,
so we went to the probate in Gatmar, because how old were you?
14.
But I was, he said, you could tell you going on school.
We got married.
My parents didn't know it.
He would come back.
So you were still living at home?
Yeah, I was still at home, but I was living with my sister in high school,
because she lives in a little city where the high school was.
We lived in country.
But he would come to my sister's house, but he was afraid to go to my mom and dad to see her.
So somebody, his brother found out, I guess he told his brother that we had got married.
And his brother went down and talked to my mom and dad and told her,
so you know, people, you are married right here.
And they said, yeah, I didn't know they were married.
Marriage, how do you hear of anybody?
And they said, did you know your baby daughter had been there by baby brother?
And what did he say?
How did he know?
And dad is all dough.
I know that's not true.
But I guess they eventually got old.
And they just crazed about him.
He was so nice to me, because just like I said, I didn't know how to end thing.
Everything I did was by him with him.
I cooked one day.
And as I got older, I realized it was a mess.
He said, I tell you what, let's not eat.
We had rice and something else.
He said, let's not eat it, because I had stirred it.
I thought he was going to stir it.
And he had got gum.
He said, I tell you what, let's not eat that today.
We go and get us something else.
I said, okay, so we went and later on, he teased me about it.
My sister came up there and they said, well,
you just said, I don't know how you making it.
She kept cooking.
He said, I don't care.
It's good to me.
Everything I cooked was good to him.
He said, and my sister said, well, you see in there, because it's not good.
And they kept that up, teased me all the time, but I couldn't.
But I finally learned how to, because going to school and teach his home baking,
you know, and learning how to do a lot of things.
And we got along really good.
He never, he never got angry at me about anything.
We just, we had all of the difference.
But we always before we go to bed, we cleared up.
I said, I'm going home.
He said, if you go there, I'm going to.
We lived together 18 years.
And it was a beautiful 18 years.
And as the kids grew, sure, it was my oldest daughter.
And she was graduating at, and we were just looking forward to go, she wanted to go to Fort Valley.
Before Fort Valley.
And he taught, what he said, he said, when you look up, I'll be standing out there on that campus
and see what little boy you be walking around.
And she believed in that too.
I told him if he had lived, all of my daughters would be in old maids.
Because he just didn't feel like they need to get married.
Nobody was good enough for his daughter.
I'm sure he would have changed it as they got older.
But I teased him that son, if your dad had lived, you'd been old.
They said, we know that.
But he was a really good father.
And I still miss my husband.
I've been 47 years.
I never married anymore.
And the memory of him still lingered with me.
And I can't hardly talk about it up until this day.
I really can't.
It's something that I hope nobody ever ever happened to.
Because when he, coming up this month at my, it's always a hot month for me.
Because he got killed in March.
March, 15th.
And we'd be there the moment, 25th.
And we would take the fact that I have another six child.
I waited eight years.
And my mother was sick.
I told her I said, I just don't want no more tears.
I'm afraid there'd be another girl.
She said, just try one more time.
Try one more time.
You might have a boy.
And I told him, I said, my mother, she died that same night.
We were talking.
I said, we go ahead and trap her boy.
And he told everybody before he died, the baby was born in June.
He gave out cigars in January.
To everybody, Kobe had a stone.
He'd celebrate his boy.
He said, they didn't have son of a man back to him.
But he told everybody we'd be at the house.
He'd be at the room.
He painted it blue.
And everything he was geared to, the baby, he knew it was going to be a boy.
He told everybody.
And I said, you know what, I guess the dog, the old lady, in him.
Because he was more happy of that time, the night with me being pregnant.
He was in the other town.
Because I don't care where we would go.
He would tell somebody, look at my wife.
Don't she look good?
We have it out boy this time.
But he got killed in March.
And the baby was born in June.
And the doctors, when I was going to, he told the doctor, say this is my boy this time.
So when the baby was born, they wouldn't let me name nothing but Jose.
They said, they don't put nothing but Jose, June, his baby.
He wanted him so bad.
We just hate he didn't see it.
But he looks just like his dad.
I tell him all the time, he even got ways like it.
I say, you're dead or living in here because you got too many ways like it.
So I thank God for all of my children.
Can we talk a little bit about that day?
I love it.
That morning, he got up, we had a store.
He got up and left me in bed and he went down to the store.
And it was a man staying there helping him with a little house down from us.
He got him to come back up and tell me that he was going with this guy.
He'd come to get his cow.
And I said, okay.
And my brother was there.
Your brother came up and stopped him.
Your brother's name?
Vernon Hall.
And he wrote where he asked him to go with him right now, they put a guy to get that cow.
And say, when they got right, they took the [neighbor's] pasture with a cow.
Well, he had been in our pastor about three months.
Okay.
And he wanted something to say, no, that's my cow over there.
It's one of some other cows.
It's my husband told him to say, no, that's my cow.
I kept your cows all this time.
You go come here and try and take my cow.
And he said, well, I'll tell you what, we'll let the law sell it.
And said, my husband walked out the pastor, the pastor, and the guy, he shot him.
The guy.
He shot him in the back.
He shot him right through here.
It might have been a little buckshot, because he lived about a week when he shot him.
So did you hear the gun shot at all?
Oh, I could hear it.
It was a distance from half.
But my brother got him and carried him to the hospital.
And the guy, what was staying with us, worker, he came back up there and told me that the guy had shot him.
Okay, and what was his name, do you remember?
George Williamson.
Williamson, okay.
And I don't know, somebody came, I was just, I had been carrying me over there.
And when I got a little bit of a transfer to the Albion.
Okay.
But he was able to talk to me.
And all of his brothers came and wanted to stay with him, because I could, you know, I was just, I couldn't stay with him.
So he came to stay with him.
Okay.
And so he told you everything that happened, right?
He was able to stay with him.
Yeah, he could tell everybody about him.
Right.
He talked.
And I really thought he was getting better, because I was getting dressed that morning.
Like every time I was going to see him, he would get worse.
And they said, well, maybe you need to stay with him.
I think it was just the idea.
The pain.
Yeah, the pain for him was me.
Thinking that he made a...
And he knew how I was there.
And so I was that morning, I said, I'm going.
I said, I don't care what, nobody said I'm going.
And just as I got up and got dressed, one of his brothers came in and told me at 6 o'clock in the morning, he passed.
And that was eight off for ten, for me and my kids.
I hope nobody ever had to go to nothing like that, because I had those kids.
I had never worked.
And had them to take care of and expect them a baby.
And nobody, I hope nobody ever had to go through that.
That was a hard time.
And then they started to move me in Baker County after that.
And my kids was involved with it all the way through.
But I couldn't because my baby was just three weeks old when they started.
But they went to jail.
But when the people were marched and come back, they'd come out to the house and eat and sit out on the lawn.
You think that helped you begin to heal or begin to grow up?
Yeah, they're whole communities that they just do it by me, the whole community did.
And it really helped.
I don't know what I would have done if I hadn't had loving people in the community like I had.
Because I had a sister in law stayed with me at night.
And I had a friend that lived close to me stayed until in the night.
Trying to help us to heal.
The kids would come in from school.
And that was the real time that they would be with their dad.
He would be there, helping with homework, and playing with them and doing things.
And that was a hard time for them.
They just went through so hard time.
But after the baby came, it started to help us a lot.
We had him to play with it.
They never had a brother.
And it started to help to release some of the pains of them.
Okay.
What helped them to do the male in the shelter?
He finally died.
They didn't even like him up.
They didn't even end dating.
But he died.
And you tried to take him to trial or you tried to?
We tried to.
On three separate occasions, right?
Right.
And the first time what happened, how?
They had an all-white year.
Okay.
And all the real men's was big account of men's.
And they knew him.
And they didn't even end dating.
So the next time we came to Albany, and never happened.
And he was never arrested or questioned anything?
And he used to, well, the main thing of it going back, he was my dad.
And my dad is brother.
And I grew up with him.
You know, I didn't understand it.
Because I always, he was at Ivo House.
I grew up around him.
So you knew this?
And I don't know what happened.
They said he said that he was a diabetic.
That's what they said.
He never told me anything.
I never talked to him anymore.
Because I didn't even want to see him anymore.
Because when I would meet him, like my blood would just go up and top my head.
And I just had to print his God.
Don't let me feel that way.
Because I knew it was engine mean.
But then somebody told him how I felt or something.
And he stopped coming through our way.
He'd go around the other way.
And he said, were it to tell me that he wasn't going to harm me in the kids?
But it was just here.
Really well.
I'd like to back up a little bit in terms of you talked about the Baker County movement.
And I'm wondering if your husband was at all political.
Was he a person who was registering?
I know in 1958, blacks began to start to register.
Was he among this group of black men?
We was the first two that registered in Baker County.
We got up that morning and he had to go pay tax.
And he said, get dressed and come go with me down.
We're going to pay tax.
It's more than I'm going to ask them.
I want to tell them I want to register.
So we stopped by my sister and they had a little cafe down in the city.
And told her what we was going to do.
And she said, well, I'm going to her name is Joseph Miller.
She said, if you are registered, I'm going to register too.
And she said, if that man do anything to you with the two of us, we're going to get him.
So we felt strong.
He knew we were going back and forth.
But he wasn't a friend.
But the guy who I was the register, he was so nervous he could not even get the pay-by-out for the register.
But he let us register.
And so we went back in the community and told everybody that we had registered the vote.
And we got people to go down.
And then they changed it.
The little card that they gave us was a small card with just your citizen, the United States, Baker County.
They got a long sheet because they felt like a lot of the people could read it right.
And that was stopped them from voting.
So then we had the card get the justice department to come in.
And Toronto came in and we got the justice department to come in.
And they changed it.
And we got everybody to vote.
So were you aware of the, like in 1950, there were some bombings in 1958?
That was my uncle.
And then the my uncle, he tried to vote.
And friends of ours, Mr. Benjamin Cunning, a card brought away.
And Mr. Ackie King.
Joshua Williams.
That was my uncle.
He was the old man too.
He was down in his 80s.
But he really wanted to register the vote.
And they went out and tried to register.
And that night they came back and bombed his house.
Mr. Cough brought away.
They bombed his car.
Mr. Ackie King, they bombed his car.
And Mr. Cunningham, they put whiskey.
They stopped whiskey.
They call it.
It's whiskey that they made.
They called it stunk back then.
And they put it around his house.
And they told him that they heard he was running stomp whiskey.
And he told him he never ran his stomp whiskey.
Right.
And they went around the house.
They had put it around there and found it.
And told him that was it.
And they arrested him.
And he stayed in jail about two weeks.
Now they knew they wouldn't give him a bond.
He had some friends in Bainbridge, Georgia.
He said, this pastor got some of his friends to come up and bond him out.
And they got him out of jail that way.
But they was finished in prison.
But only by him having a pastor that knew somebody, a lawyer in Bainbridge, Georgia.
They got him out.
That was the Gator Johnson at that time.
I know you might not have heard him.
That was out of sheer.
That was the Gator Johnson.
The Gator Johnson they called him.
He could pass through Newton.
Right.
He was just tough.
And he would growl at any time a black person came in.
Make a know, isn't it?
Right.
Sarah, I can go just like it.
Okay.
So let's move forward back into the 65 after your husband is killed
and the movement sort of takes off.
And your house becomes sort of like the a meeting headquarters.
And Charles Sherrod comes in.
And I mean, what are you thinking about this?
You know what happened to me?
At that time when they were congregated in my house.
My husband just had built a house.
Okay.
He stayed one week in the house.
He got killed.
And it was a late family cheering service down in Newton.
I went down and tried to apply the help we would.
So for the kids.
Right.
But they were they were turning away.
She wrote the guy who was in there that if they say man,
she got him to, uh, brought him out there and saying that I was
violating the law, that I let those people come out of my house.
And I had built the house to farm his home.
Right.
So we call it Justice Department in Atlanta.
I mean, Washington.
Right.
And they told us as long as I was paying my payment.
They had nothing to do with it.
And he better not come out there.
He almost lost his job from it.
And I didn't have any more trouble.
Right.
But they tried to take my house.
So now I understand they did some cross burnings on your.
Oh, after then they integrated school down there.
My kids was some of the first one.
The state patrol blocked them.
We couldn't get in there.
But they went on the school there and found a guy in there.
Okay.
And they run across and in front of my house one of my daughters
was at the time when they were getting her homework out.
I was in bed and she said, mother said it's a five years.
It's a lot of cars.
And I jumped up and you could see the cross burning.
And I tell you what, you can get so angry too.
You don't think about this.
I guess my husband loves her.
He loves to clear her.
And he had plenty of ammunition around him.
And he had told those girls how to shoot.
So I was giving one to go and told one to get on the telephone.
And I had one.
I had to pump gun.
And I was on the porch and I was pumping that gun.
The fastest I could.
I said they might get me, but I'm going to leave one out here.
So my neighbor saw that the kid's called him.
And he saw that he got his car and he drove down there.
And my brother that got him and my brother-in-law walked.
He started shooting.
And when he jumped out of the car and drove past him,
it started shooting.
And they started leaving.
And I don't know, but I really believe some of them got some bullets in them.
Because it was some fire going on.
And about an hour ago, it was about 50,
and it hit the black minz in my yard.
And we called the sheriff.
the sheriff was in it because I recognized a lot of those men.
But I recognized him.
Because I could see from the fire.
They were that close to my house.
And so the sheriff talked to the head of the Justice Department would call them out there.
She talked to them first instead of talking to me.
So I told them, I said, well, you talked to them.
And I said, that's it for me to say.
He said, well, I want to get to them for you as today,
but in the cross, and I told you.
But he said that some of the guys told them they were possible.
And they sat there, and they woke up and feel the cross in front of my house.
But I had just enough to know in my eyes,
because see what was going on.
You knew what that meant.
Right.
And we had them brought them to federal court,
but nothing happened.
Okay.
Baker County was a county you couldn't get.
And it's almost like that right now.
Okay.
You can't get enough justice there.
So one of the things that I was intrigued about that particular story was that the tree line phone.
I mean, what was that phone that you got on to contact people?
Was that like a regular phone or what?
Yeah, it was a regular phone.
It was just a regular phone.
We got on the phone and called everybody that we knew that was in the movement.
And those men came.
Okay.
And for about two months, they watched my house.
They come every night and stayed about 12 o'clock.
Okay.
And my kids and I could sleep.
Because it was a frightening time.
It was frightening for me and my kids.
We was afraid to go to sleep.
Right.
Because you could hear one night I was in the bed and I didn't let them know what happened.
A bullet hit my window and glass was down on the floating next morning.
And one of my daughters asked me why I was that glass down there.
I said, I don't know.
I said, maybe I don't know what to share.
But I knew who they had.
Right.
I just didn't want them to be afraid.
So we were, I would take them to head to a flood and then do that time that year.
And they wanted to go see the water.
And I carried my kids down to see the water.
And some of the white guys were down there.
And they were teasing each other going on about the man kid, the cune.
They down here, but that cune got kid and all of that.
And my kids went through a lot.
Even in school.
They would be talking to them.
They'd come home crying.
And I would tell them, I said, well, you got to do it.
It's a week praying.
I said, because you're going up to get what they're trying to get.
Right.
And I said, you try to get all you can while you're in.
I said, I know it's hurt.
It caused me just as bad.
I said, but we just got to go through it.
It finally got better.
Right.
But it was all of those kids that went to school at that time.
They really caught it.
From the teachers and the kids.
Right.
And my daughter told me when they said they was in the lunchroom and one of the teachers came
to let that nigger, so they wouldn't say nigger.
Let that nigger get by.
They said so.
So they could say it, but they said it the way they want to say it.
So ugly.
Right.
And one day I had to go up there to the school.
They called me, had my daughter and my baby girl there.
And it's super tennis after.
And I was so upset.
I was like, what did she do?
And they said, well, you come to the superintendent office.
She said that.
And it's super tennis office was down in the little town.
The principal had carried her down there.
And she sent up in there when I got there.
And I was so upset.
And what happened, and the little thing didn't happen.
She said it was a big fat white guy that got there.
They told her she was liking him.
And she had a nephew.
Now he was really handsome.
My brother's both handsome.
She told the white girl that she liked him.
And she told the principal, they can't hurt her.
The superintendent office, the principal did.
And I got there.
I told him I didn't like it.
And I hope this didn't happen anymore.
I said, I wish that girl could get a boy in his handsome.
Is my nephew.
That's right.
That old big girl.
Now, fat boy, she tried to put, say my daughter like it.
And I said, I wouldn't want her to even say anything to him.
But they didn't take another one down.
Because they knew I meant what I said.
And I told them down there with two men's in the office, my little daughter.
And both of them was white.
And I was just upset because the way they were treating them, they could have done anything.
That didn't happen anymore.
And then...
We're going to pause for just a second.
Okay, sorry.
That's okay.
Okay.
So let's talk about the, go back to the Baker County movement after 65.
And you worked on voter registration.
Would you deem it a success?
How long was it a real uphill battle?
And how long did...
Did SNCC stayed in Baker County before they started to see any real success?
They stayed in Baker County probably about two years after them.
Yeah, Sherrod I came in there.
And it was the funny thing.
He started dating my oldest daughter.
Sure, the most important to college.
He got married to us all that's about oldest daughter.
But he's the best son-in-law and the best home she could have gotten.
Okay.
So after the movement died, you became somewhat politically active in the community around education.
How did you get involved in that?
Well, that one made me get involved when I went out there and my daughter was sitting
at the Superintendents office.
Okay.
And I knew somebody had to do something.
To be a voice for the kids.
Yeah, I was working.
I worked at a large rate place in Newton.
I got a job there.
And I was sitting there at the office one day and I said,
I'm going to ask the people what they vote for me if I went on further voter education.
So I went to the meeting, had the mass meeting.
And I got up and I asked them,
where did you have the mass meeting?
We had it now in Springfield.
Springfield, okay.
I asked them what they vote for me if I were wrong.
What do they think about it?
And everybody in the church said that would be a great idea if I were wrong.
They were supporting me.
Okay.
So that time to pay in,
I was going to go down the paying and I had my cousin say,
I'm a G Suite.
He said, I'm not going to let you go by yourself.
I'm going with you.
Right.
And then he said, what time are you coming down?
I said, well, when we have our break at 10 o'clock, I'll be down in paying.
Okay.
And then I told him, I got it, I want to pay in for a rougher voter education.
And he told me I was to pay in all of it.
How much did you have to pay?
I had that time with just 35 dollars.
Okay.
And so I paid in and I started going right,
but by the time I got home that afternoon, I paid in to run a new district that was
where the city, because that's where I was already voted.
By the time I got home, he called me.
He said, Grace, say you know that you're not in the new district.
I said no, I said I've been voting all the time there.
I thought that's where I was.
He said no.
So we checked the binary, you didn't ever deal with this.
He said, you want your money back?
I said no, I don't care why I am I'm wrong.
Right.
So he said, okay.
And I ran against two white guys.
And I was in a runoff with one.
And I've been on their the board until 2013, I resigned.
I retired from it.
Okay.
Just got it.
But I had, I worked so hard.
I tell all of young people, I said, if you run it, you've got to get out of work.
Right.
And so you've got to go and say your vote to the people I went from.
Dota Dota, White and Black.
And if they were picking peas, I picked peas, if they was picking butter beans, whatever.
Right.
And I got out and kept the shelling peas.
And they talked to them.
I said, they told them, I said, I'm for quality education for all I choose.
I want to work for all of the children in bank account that I'm concerned about.
And I ran into one problem with, he was old.
Okay.
He was feeding his hogs that day one day.
And I drove up and he said, can I help you?
I hope you can.
As my name is Grace Milden.
I'm running for the bank account of older education.
And I said, I would love if you were both of them.
It's because my platform is quite a good education for all I choose.
And he said, you know what?
I might just vote.
But you know, young niggas don't give up to you.
And I said, now this one, not going to give up.
I said, when I tell you what, I would appreciate if you vote for me.
That's the only one gave me a negative tone.
And I would take my experience with my first, I won the election and run off.
And the guy shook my hand and he said, we will always be friends.
And the way I can help you, I will do that.
I told him, thank you.
I appreciate it.
So when we had the first vote meeting, it's super tender to say it out.
This is our new vote, remember, Miss Grace Milden?
I don't know whether all of you all know her or not.
It was the old man on that white guy.
I mean, he's about 80-something years old.
He looked like he was.
His name was Roy Kelly.
And he had lost his bill for him.
And my dad had found his bill for him.
And he said, oh, your parents asked him, my dad is named Joe Nathan Hall.
My mother's name is Danny Hall.
He said, Joe was one of the best niggas I could say in big kind of state.
I lost my life saving in my bill for him.
He found it and he gave it to me.
And he said, I just thought that he said, I thought I would never get it.
Right.
He said, but he was on his main.
And so he always told all of us on it.
But when he said niggas, the other four of them, they looked at it and it's super tender to say it out.
He looked at me and I guess they thought I was going to say something.
They don't say something.
But I tell them I said, I can understand Mr. Kelly.
He doesn't say it niggas so much.
He didn't realize what he ate.
But it was a young guy that I said, but Wayne, if you didn't say it, would have made it different.
Right.
With me.
I said, but Mr. Kelly didn't realize what he said.
But I want you to understand this.
I said, I was a little worried sometimes I might get upset.
And I might say cracker and I want you to take it away.
And we never had any, I worked with them.
I never had any problems.
I learned one thing.
I had to listen and I had to learn.
Then I had to work with them.
And they worked with me.
Any problem that we had, they were explaining to me.
And if I said my opinion in there, they looked like they were really, uh, respect my opinion.
And then when I would say to them tell them something, they did the same thing.
So we really got along.
Because they saw I wouldn't in there to try to be bullied.
Right.
I wouldn't in there to try to do the only thing I was concerned about, I kids in Baker County.
And that's my thought until I left the kids in Baker County.
We had a problem with that.
But I'd be right there.
And I tell them, I said, the only thing I'm concerned is about I children.
And we can just educate our kids.
We'll be less aware of that.
Right.
It will be less crimes.
All of us work together and try to help these kids.
Okay.
That's my philosophy up until this day.
It's here in the Baker County.
Okay.
So, um, I guess in the Baker County movement, what transpired and the state of education today,
what are some of the larger issues that you think still plague education for blacks?
And even blacks in Baker County period, what are some of the issues that troubled them?
Well, the trouble that is the issues now with me, we get all white voting set one.
And she just said, they came in there, fight out of attorney first, fight out superintendent.
He's black.
He got in there with the school was in debt.
He's got an ice cream ladder debt.
And he's doing a good job.
The teachers, the children, I respect him.
And now they, uh, go pay him out of his contract.
And the contract is up in June, whether he's got a year contract.
But until June school is out, they could have let him stay down because the CRCT test is coming up.
CRCT.
A CRCT.
Okay.
A CRCT test.
Yes.
It's coming up.
And, um, he knows about the testing and, and all, and they're getting him out of there.
And they don't respect him at all.
The first meeting they had instead of accepting his agenda, they brought their own agenda.
And seeing for, when you have a agenda, you just put public side.
They didn't public side.
They just brought their own agenda when he even pay attention to his agenda, uh, at all.
Okay.
And, and they not giving no respect to him.
And then law, you let them go, they got a new law.
And I know he no better because he's from all over him.
He's over him.
He isn't in this side.
George.
Right.
Time to come, but he's letting them do what they want to do.
Get by with things that we know because we've had training.
And we know some of those things on that.
He's in the valley.
And it just got in about upset.
Okay.
Every about upset in the kind of how they're doing.
Ask them.
So you think it's going backwards?
It's going to, they try and get it.
It's going to be a good deal.
I hope that we can stop them before it goes too far.
Okay.
Because a lot of citizens are concerned.
They had a meeting last, on the 28th of February, and it was standing on, we were about 200
people there.
Let them know that they just did, it's just satisfied with what going on.
And it's 90% black.
Go ahead.
90% black school.
Okay.
And these people, they don't seem to understand it.
I don't really care.
I don't know what it is.
I won't say it goes out of nowhere.
Okay.
But it just hurt.
And see things going lately.
Okay.
So when all this stuff began to happen with your daughter, Shirley Shurard, a couple of
years ago, with the Department of Agriculture, how did that make you, I mean, I read in the
book that you know you called your daughter crying when you first heard about it, but that
was just like the night they kept my husband.
They were trying to keep me from knowing it.
They know how I emotionally am.
Right.
But what I'm called me and told me, did I hear the news?
I said, no, I was in bed.
It said, well, the guy has five, we call him.
And so she had to stop on the highway and turn her imagination in.
And I said, well, so I tried to get it and I never could get it in there.
So I got up early at morning and I was just crying all the way going to home.
And I made it.
And when I got there, seeing him, I was at her house.
And I couldn't talk to her.
I turned him around, but she saw my car when I passed the winter.
And I went to one of my other daughters's house.
And she asked the man to let her stop long enough to talk to her mother.
And she said, I was crying.
So she said, mother, I'm crying.
I'm fine.
I said, I'm crying.
So I am fine.
I want you to know I'm fine.
But it was her.
I think that was a really hurt thing.
The way they treated her.
Right.
You know, if they could have let her go to her office, you know, let her go into her office.
But they stopped on the highway.
My daughter didn't even know anybody on that highway.
Anything could have happened to her.
And I just don't see the reason for them that she had to do it.
She said they had arrested her all the way.
She had to do it.
But I told them that the body hundreds of them would have come get me.
Because I would have made sure I got in the light.
I didn't went on to the office.
And then I would turn him around.
I wouldn't stop on the highway.
But you know, everybody different.
She felt like she had to do it.
Okay.
But anyway, she told them to go interview the whole tape.
And they wouldn't listen to her.
And when they finally did.
And then when they told me what was there.
I said, I didn't raise no food.
I said, if she thought that she wouldn't spoke to her.
Right.
I said, I didn't raise no food.
I know that.
And then I knew she hadn't seen it.
Right.
But those people that came to her rescue, they were so wonderful.
They invited her to the Liberty Party, he was 90 years old.
He was still driving, 18 frustration.
I wish you have needed them.
They were just nice.
They could be here.
So the community field in Bake Your County is still pretty much intact.
What'd you say in the stadium?
So it's not like we were surprised to be the younger people.
I found one thing that was pretty fabled up.
You know the younger people.
I fight out one thing.
If you don't know your history, your PC,
we need to get with our kids lower about the history
of weather.
There's a lot of them don't even know that what happened.
And they don't even know that we couldn't even go to the
cooled-water [fountain].
They didn't even know that we couldn't sit in the same rooms
when we go to the doctor.
They had separate colors on one side and white on the other
side.
A lot of these kids today don't know that because things
ain't already happened.
We had already suffered through it and got it for them.
And they just don't.
I think we need to make sure they get more history.
What going on it might be make the whole thing.
But see, now in school, they don't give it to them.
Was that something you tried to push on while you were
on the school board?
Yeah, but we have a wonderful program.
And nothing else about it.
OK.
It's on the school year.
But I think it needs to be a lot of it.
Like kids should know the history.
Maybe they would do better.
OK.
We would do better.
And maybe the whole community would do better.
It would be more love if the younger, quiet and black would
know what happened.
Because I've seen a lot of them once, now that they wouldn't
come down nothing like that.
But they just don't know.
OK.
So about your experiences in Baker County,
that you think?
Well, all the things that I know, that I could say,
that I had a birthday.
I was 80 years old.
And I just thank God to be able to help in the community.
Because I don't think it's nobody if you go to have two
roles named after me.
The school role is named Grace Little Circus.
And the role, because by my house, it's named Grace Little
Road.
So I just don't think, but I didn't wait till I die.
They did it while I'm alive.
I got to smell some of the flowers while I'm alive.
And I'm just so happy over there.
You don't know really how you touch other people's lives
until they let you know.
So I feel like I have done my best.
If I don't do any more, I feel like I have done my best
for that county.
OK.
So I've been on all kind of boards.
And I work honestly with them.
And I earned a respect from them.
And they have earned it for me.
OK.
Well, thank you so much, Mr. Miller, for pointing
on my question.
OK.
Could you tell me, John, me and just very shortly,
what the story of your daughter's problem
was in what her position was and what happened?
She was the first director of agriculture
of Ag and state of Georgia.
And I just feel like it was a thing out from the beginning.
Because while somebody had a meeting,
they knew she was speaking at this NAACP meeting.
And while somebody had to sneak around
to try to get some information.
So I feel like it was sort of set up at this
like that she was in.
And that's my feeling about it.
And now people, that's the way I feel in my heart about it.
So the story was that she went to this NAACP meeting
and gave a speech and spoke about it.
She was trying to convince the people
that how we need to come together.
And she said, if I can do it, I feel like it should be doing
because anybody else could do,
was her father got killed by a white man when she was young.
And she forgave and she tried to help.
Only thing she was just trying to say is that we need
to come together as a people.
And she told the story of the Spooner, the mayor,
Spooner who won.
And the Spooner heard it on the,
well, one of the songs that he was watching at TV.
And he told his mother, went up to the house
to tell his mother, the mother father said,
they got your friend in trouble.
They said, turn on TV.
And they turned on TV.
And he said, they tried to call.
And they couldn't get through, but they called CNN.
His song got CNN.
And he was at CNN, it was at her house.
And they told her, say, share this, I believe this is somebody
that you would love to talk to on the phone.
And they talked to them and let them
know that it was a lie.
They shared a hip thing.
Because she said they came to Harvard twice.
And the white guy they had, wasn't helpful.
But she found somebody to help them.
She said it was the last minute.
But whoever this guy that she got was her friend.
And they were looking for help to save the family.
Save the lives.
They found them.
And they own that farm now.
Because they had this birthday.
It was in November, because it was just getting cold.
Because that went down.
They wouldn't be coming with them.
And it's a beautiful place, then.
And they just so thankful.
They still have boys.
They all year round their father and mother.
And they just happened.
And they were able to save it.
And I'm so thankful to them that they came
for it.
It's the right time for her.
Thank you, Miss Miller again.
I hope I didn't.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress
and the Smithsonian National Museum
of African-American history and culture.